one time i got pulled over speeding and
then i told the guy well i'm looking for
a party and then i said this is the
address
and he went oh it's right back that way
and then he escorted me to the high
school party
hello and welcome to the roast of your
teenage self podcast
i am your host your roast coming
queen uh the embittered runner-up in the
virginia high school league's one act
play competition of 2006
elise morales and with us today
we have a comedian who you know as the
creator and star of the president show
as mayor brett on three busy debras and
as the host
of coffee talk with tony but before all
of that
he was a graduate of hamilton wenham
regional high school class of 1993.
it's anthony antaminic hi i'm old
i actually do think you are the first
person who
is going to be representing this time
period on the podcast so i'm very
was it the gen x right isn't that the
whole thing now we're supposed to like
save society according to like
right-wing blogs
yeah i think the right-wing blogs
actually are i think that
i think that the the thing they're
saying is that it's up to gen
x to get mad about [ __ ]
and make sure that [ __ ] oh yes yeah
yes that's it that's it i i it's funny
because
uh i i mean not that the you know
generations that's somewhat true but
then it's also sort of like horoscopes
it's like it's true and it's not
yeah um but it's funny because if there
was any i guess generation that you
should not ask for help
it would be us because we're like we
don't give i don't give a flying [ __ ]
what's happening i mean
i just want to stay safe and make sure i
mean i care about things are happening
but
i don't care about any of this like sort
of
you know posturing about we need to stop
these people we need to stop
these young people who are the [ __ ]
people it's so
nuts it's also it's interesting to
to your point to ask for the generation
whose
literal motto was whatever to get
angry about your stupid [ __ ] that
they don't care about
no i'm just excited when david byrne
does something that's basically
that's basically what's going on for me
do you feel that you
personally embody a gen x
persona or do you feel like a
representative of the gen
x thing uh i don't see myself as like a
representative
in the sense that i i yeah i wouldn't
call myself that
uh but i do uh yeah i mean i identify
with that i mean i think
a lot of that is just all
you know generations have a zeitgeist
and within that zeitgeist you have your
points of reference
you could argue in some ways that our
generation has the fortune
in a way in this good and bad but the
fortune of
a lot of the things that basically are
genre defining in media
and things that sustain decades later
uh like i mean back to the future as
just a
most pat example yes that is now
beyond a movie right it's a sort of
iconic or
or or genre defining thing
it extends beyond that it marks a point
in time
maybe because it's a time travel movie
so i think that
people who grew up in that because of
the sustaining pap
media it has a lot to do with also
that the sustaining power of media
started to solidify
around that time right it's when we
start recording and duplicating
video in a way that's accessible to the
common person
and then the sustaining power of that
media continues to inform
the next generation and subsequent
generation of media that follows
that so in that sense it has probably a
lot of power
generationally because you have
the most sustaining um uh
presence of that media so in that sense
and since we're such a media driven
society i think it it
obviously i identify with
being a generation i guess but i also
don't know if this
is true but i think the generation that
you know
i was the latchkey kid and i learned how
to cook when i was eight
and made food for myself and
multi-generational families and
yeah i would leave my home for hours on
my own when i was seven
eight you know there was no question
about
you know that that you do things on your
own um
and the cold war and all those different
things that sort of we identify with
and i would definitely say the like
period of music
and film at that time projected an
identity of aloofness
and apathy and so of course you
duplicate
your you or you you try to replicate the
archetypes you see
and so then yeah you know there's
definitely that
but i guess it's also a matter of that
was a time
of when the way you communicated was you
know you wandered off in the woods with
your friends and [ __ ] around for three
hours or
you know the classic story of hiding the
porn mags in the
in the woods and all those things so
when you have a common
generational understanding of those
things i you know then yeah in that
sense i identify with it
but uh i don't think i'm like you know
i'm not grooving out to the cure
you know pipe dancing when i'm alone
[Laughter]
so okay this is one of the first
questions that i always
like to ask uh just to like place our
setting uh yeah so hamilton wenham
regional high school what like flavor
of high school are we talking here
public private big
small etcetera uh
one thing i should say is that my
freshman year was actually
technically the senior year of a private
school i went to so ninth grade was like
the last year
of glen urquhart school where i went my
best friend dave
who is still my my best friend um
we we met in sixth grade he was going to
go to hamilton wenham and the question
was would i go to concord academy
or go to like a private school or
whatever but then when i learned that
dave was going to hamilton wenham which
is only a few towns away from
where my private school glen erker was
we looked up the school and it's uh uh
and so hamilton wenham is in a very it's
probably one of the best districts
in all of massachusetts okay
i live in i lived in chelsea which is
one of the worst districts
in all of massachusetts so there was a
school choice program which i think now
is a very like right
ring idea i guess but uh school choice
afforded me the ability
to not go to chelsea public school uh
if i was going to choose a public school
and allowed me to apply to go to
hamilton wenham
hamilton wenham is the hamilton is the
birthplace of general patton
okay um it's a very protestant
white anglo-saxon protestant
town okay lots of old money
when gilhane maxwell went to hide after
epstein had been arrested
he went to the neighboring town of
manchester
which is manchester by the sea and
this whole area of towns are
all a mix of blue bloods and then like
really poor catholics and um
so uh hamilton wentham is a
i think my graduating class had
maybe a hundred people in it i think
it's not a big high school
but it is a very like brady bunch meets
john hughes high school okay very
classic like have the car
park the car in the lot like any high
school movie you can think of of the 80s
or
early 90s that's where i went to school
you know i went to a very 70s one floor
school type thing yeah oh okay so you
only it was just like
all spread out on one level yes and we
had the first i'm sorry we had the first
project adventure course in the united
states
uh which is adventure you could get on
the roof of the high school and
zip line into the woods
yeah yeah and there was a whole course
you could do
ropes and climb trees and uh uh
yeah could you do this and like was this
something you did during pe
or like well there was no well it was
part of physical
phys ed was the the project adventure
block
but um you could also request to zipline
[Laughter]
okay what what i have so many questions
about this
yeah what was the process to request
and was it something that would happen
after school or would they be like
no free block free block
basically a group of kids would go we
want to do the zip line then you'd go
to the pe teacher and go can we go up
and do zipline
and she'd be like i have a free block at
you know a b
block and so then everyone would go up
on b block and and zip line
and then you would zip line yeah okay
yeah on study hall blocks
you know okay i'm kind of understanding
but well i like i mean
like it was a very i don't know is it uh
um you know you had free blocks which
was study hall
which weren't nests it wasn't necessary
that you had to be in the cafeteria
you know you could you could kind of do
what you wanted
and um uh they i think we're very proud
of that
course so believe it or not most people
never
were like let's go ziplining it was kind
of considered geeky and lame to go
do the project adventure [ __ ] high
schoolers like you have a zip line on
the roof
go every day what are you talking about
nobody wanted to do yeah so so
yes that that was uh i think a notable
thing about the school
that is an extremely i mean i'll say
you're the first person
on this podcast to say that they had a
zipline
and i'm this poor kid from chelsea
who's you know been folded into this
community because
a lot of some of the kids who went to
hamilton wenham i went to preschool with
when i lived in topsfield which is also
part of this
hamilton manchester block but when my
parents divorced
my dad left they sold the house and then
we moved in with my grandparents in
chelsea
so it was like this weird loop back
where there were kids
in high school who i knew when i was in
preschool but then i
like went on a whole other track so did
you
have a when you were gonna make this
jump now then go to hamilton when i'm
high school did you
how did teen anthony feel about that
like were you
anxious did you feel out of place at
this other school
oh yeah i mean i think one glen arc it
was so small there was what i think
12 people in our ninth grade class like
that was like a
very small private school you knew
everybody and it was
a a scottish private school in
was there a religious aspect to it at
all or just uh if
anything pagan like there was no
seriously
like there was nature worship and like
there was uh
a syria it was built on an old estate
and the person who owned the estate
had built these tributary statues
and sort of um little like buildings
throughout the woods
on this path and they were all tributes
to antiquity
and to esoteric symbolism and it was the
nature walk so like there
and also glenn urquhart is where loch
ness is located in scotland
so there was actually a very like it was
a uh not a like religious school by any
stretch
but they would definitely uh emphasize
the dark arts
i like to put it that way um so
okay i want to let's
put a pin in your transition for one
second because i want to ask this
what attracted your parents to
the dark arts school well my
friend ben conway's mother ruth conway
taught at glen urquhart and i had just
finished a year at a
school called beaver country day which
was yes which used to be an all-girls
school everyone always
makes a fun joke that used to be the big
joke around school
and uh in fact where i went to college
emerson was the original location of
beaver country day
in the city and then they they moved but
anyway it was an
awful private school too richie rich um
and another friend of mine had gone
there and of course you know my
grandparents were paying
for this because you know there was like
please don't send chelsea public schools
he'll end up a
punk um and uh so
i uh went there but i started just going
into the city and playing hooky and so i
basically skipped the second half of my
year and i had to repeat seventh grade
so when i was in that crisis i needed to
get out of dodge i wasn't going to
repeat at the same school
so i went to glenercart where i repeated
and uh and that's how i've never done
seventh grade before
were you just like no no i told
everybody
i told everybody immediately because i
i'm a firm believer in
own own your secret first so that uh
no one can define you by it so glenn
archer was really just because of ruth
conway
and that it was and it was a bit
glendrick was a great school it was a
that was a
a awesome school so
my closest friends who i still know who
i still
regularly know and this is rare i have
like four or five
friends from that period who i still
talk to and my friend dave i
regularly talk to like on you know a
bi-weekly basis so um that's why we
picked that school
and then the discovery of all the
antiquities was just sort of being there
and my friend dave and i probably blew
it up into something way bigger than it
was because we were like
into magic and all that [ __ ] uh and so
uh
there was five of us who ended up from
who
all school choice i think dave was the
only one from hamilton five of us as a
group
all said okay we're going to hw together
okay so it was weird because i was
transferring as a sophomore
some people had gone in eighth grade so
there were some people who had been
there a year longer than me who i knew
who i'd gone to school with
and i was both nervous and secure i was
nervous about going to public school not
knowing you know you
imagine all the john you stuff and it
was true jock shoving you in the lockers
and the alt kids and all that and uh uh
but my first day of orientation at that
school
i got through it i was a huge you know
geek weirdo and i had jean
shorts on like baggy jean shorts
and i was standing out in front of the
school waiting uh
for my mom to pick me up and
uh a bee flew up my shorts and
i freaked out and started punching my
own
crotch to try to get the bee out and so
this was what everyone saw
my first day of school was me flip out
and punching at my own dick
yeah and then i got stung by the bee
which i'm somewhat allergic and then had
to go to the nurse's office
my first day of school day
okay punching yourself in the dick in
front of everyone on the first day of
school is a rough one
i was um i was extremely late to my
first day of school
because i missed the bus and then and
this is like
so classic my parents like i missed the
bus and i was like i missed the bus we
got the wrong time
and then we realized that like my
parents didn't know where my high school
was
and so i was like dad you have to drive
me and he was like
what and then we got like really lost
because they had never
been there i mean
yeah i don't think my parents really
knew where it was because i started
driving pretty soon in a sophomore year
so they only
drove me a few times right because
you're a sophomore and you're older than
everyone right
yeah i got my permit at 15 and a half so
i was
i was driving at 15 and i had learners
at 15
and 15 and a half i got the license on a
permissive basis
and then you were 18 before everyone so
did you like
use your 18 year old privileges to buy
cigarettes or
i was a pretty goody two-shoes in high
school i didn't really eat
cigarettes i i had maybe a beer
once and i never smoked pot until i had
the day of my graduation
and then it's been all downhill from
there uh but yeah i didn't really do i
mean
like i think we snuck cigarettes once in
a while
uh you know before a dance or something
but
i wouldn't and you know like i wasn't
pristine but i was not the person who
was um
who was who was going nuts if anything i
would get people into 18 plus
like music shows and stuff that was the
big one so
were you were you not engaging in like
drinking or smoking or any of that stuff
because you were nervous
or were you just interested in other
things
my mom and stepfather are runners and so
that was
pounded into my head when i was young
and my mom is a dancer too so there was
just like
smoking was not an option pot seemed
scary but also my father
was what in in 1980 1989 90.
so my dad's only three years sober at
that point so i also you know had a
father who
uh i had you know known that he had a
serious drug and drinking problem
so i think i was also scared of that and
so
scared of develo of what would happen
yeah uh so all through high school i
just
that was just verboten you know i just i
just written the script in my mind that
that was verboten
and were your friends around you doing
it or were you guys all just like
none of us sir uh i mean we were pretty
big
geeks i mean i think dave drank a little
bit by senior year oh i mean i think
dave probably drank in the woods more
than i did with sean
um but no i mean it was a lot of goodie
two shoes i was friends with a lot of
goodie two-shoes or
geeks i mean dave and i you know we were
like watching excalibur
and playing nintendo like you know our
our i don't you know and like i said
once a while before a dance sure go out
to what we call the smok house which was
just basically a little
weird cement building in the middle of
the woods and we would you know
but thank god for a weird cement
building in the middle of the woods when
you're a teenager oh yeah oh
absolutely because it's also mysterious
and like
and uh and you hit you hid your
cigarettes poured and boozed there
so in that sense like yes i would take a
pull of vodka
then rinse with sepakal then take a puff
then rinse with sepakal
then take but that to me i guess i
separate that in the sense that like
we weren't like going or i wasn't going
to a friend's party and drinking beers
or
i wasn't at a friend's house and
sneaking booze out of the basement
we we did that one or two times
but i would say in the large review of
that time that was not the primary that
was not the thing that was going on for
me that so i
put it that way yeah i would say like in
my high school experience
that was going on a lot more in the
latter
half but even still like i lived across
the street from like a wooded
pond area and there were times where we
would just
go like you would think we were sneaking
out to meet up and drink but we were
actually just kind of running around in
there
yeah that's what we would do we were
just having fun yeah
yeah yeah yeah more pranks and stuff
like
you know i remember senior year we took
all the balls out of three different
mcdonald's ball pits
and then we dumped them into the parking
lot of the high school
how did you do it how did you get the
buzz
we we did it over the course of weeks
we just stole a few stole more
stole more and we had i think a kid who
worked at one
okay he let and then he let us in early
before one opened so i think two we sort
of siphoned off
half like 50 of each and then one we
took all of them
and then we all took them in our cars
and dumped them out in the parking lot
and then we had ball jousting where we
drove in our cars
down route 1a and then threw plastic
balls at each other's cars oh
my friends and i would have done that
like it like bri
i can like picture me and my friends
doing that yeah
do you do the wet paper towels would you
ever do that throw them into each
other's cars
oh yeah but we'd do it to strangers we
would throw wet paper towels in people's
faces while they were driving
we never did that but we had a
thing that we called street chaos
that um was mostly something that i did
with my two boyfriends which was a very
dramatic thing that i had going on my
senior year
fascinating me and my two boyfriends but
we played this game called street chaos
which was just
screaming at the top of your lungs at
someone who's walking down the street
while you drive by them
yeah yeah we used to call that eyeing so
you drive by
and right as you got by them you go like
that yeah
exactly you get out of them yes so you
just scream at the top of your lungs and
it scares them and it's very
funny very very funny yeah well i also
shifted clicks through
my high school and so by the end of the
we had a friend matt
workman and all of us would it was
really terrible
we would ostracize him so the idea was
called borgman chase
and so you'd pick him up to hang out but
then the idea was you kept dumping him
into different cars
and whoever was it had matt in the car
and the whole idea was to shove to
convince matt to get in a different car
and we would have full-on car chases up
and down the highway and we'd drive onto
people's lawns and [ __ ]
like it was crazy what i did my senior
year
no drinking and drugs but vehicular
recklessness
oh mad pure madness pure madness also
yeah
go on yeah so well i was just gonna say
i talked about this i think with rosebud
baker when she came on the podcast
because she grew up in the same area as
me but we
used to have like the roads to go to my
high school there were a lot of hills on
them
yeah yeah and i remember me and my
friend chelsea we would try to get
air like going up the hill to come down
crazy he didn't do that but dave still
says to me he goes you remember
the pizzeria uno's kessel run and i go
yup and i go and that's where we took it
took
what would be a 20-minute drive to the
pizzeria uno
at the like whatever that outdoor mall
was
um we i did it in eight minutes
and uh that was the big challenge we'd
put on
actually back to the future or like a
different thing and then i would try to
i think i topped at 1 30 once on the
highway
wow yeah i was mad yeah
did you get pulled over ever like were
you getting ticketed at all or
i got pulled over uh twice for speeding
once when i was going 60 and a 30
trying to get to high school and the cop
let me off
and then another time the cop let me off
because he knew my grandfather
uh and that was for radically tailgating
someone on route 1.
so i i had moments where i did i was
you know i mean i'm i'm a classic story
of a
young white male america i got pulled
over and then
sweet talk my way out of it and then
we'd all laugh and they'd
go the other way uh one time i got
pulled over
speeding and then i told the guy well
i'm looking for a party and then i said
this is the address
and he went oh it's right back that way
and then he escorted me to the high
school party
so just be safe don't be crazy
okay bye bye i see myself in you yeah
yeah it was pretty wild i mean i guess i
also learned from my
gran i think i learned from my
grandparents who were you know my
grandfather was definitely running
numbers and stuff through
you know his paint company and all that
you just learned early
the italian survival guide i think that
sort of immigrant survival guide was
you know know the cops who are like you
know the italian cops know the jewish
cops and make sure they know and uh
and then uh that way you know hopefully
i mean that that
that was the survival and yeah yeah that
was just survival is that
you'd always go oh you know my
grandfather you know you'd always sort
of try to cite something
real quick hoping that they would know
and surprisingly being from chelsea
was a huge advantage because a lot of
you know police
you know a lot of the cops would end up
coming from places like chelsea and
saugus and
everett and stuff so you could be
somewhere way north in another town and
go i'm from chelsea and they go oh i got
a cousin in chelsea and you're like okay
good
maybe i'll get out of this okay yeah
yeah i've had many run-ins with the cops
i just fortunately have only had uh one
detention
that did not result in an arrest well
i i have like i guess kind of the white
girl version of that which is just
any time i ever got in trouble for
anything i would cry so much
and for so long that
yeah i can't think of a single incident
where i got in trouble because i got
like i got i got pulled over like once
or twice for dumb stuff i got
um caught stealing at the mall i was
stealing a bra
and then i i saw that i was being
followed so i tried to put the bra
in the trash can at bath and body works
and i got the hand on my shoulder being
like
come with me um very sad cry
and i just cried and all that i got in
trouble for parking in the wrong place
in high school cried myself out of that
one
really parking in the wrong place i
they well this was a scam that my high
school rented was running and then i
re-scammed them back which is that they
made us pay an absurd amount to park
our car what yeah you would to park in
the parking lot you had to pay like 300
and i was like i don't have three
hundred dollars i make 550 an hour at
subway like i don't have
like that's crazy so
i parked in parent parking every day
because my parents bought me a pt
cruiser
and it had like cougar which is actually
a really funny
bumper sticker that probably doesn't
exist anymore but cougar mom
on the back of it
[Laughter]
and so i was just like no one's gonna
think this pc cruiser that says cougar
mom
and oakton theater is not a parent's car
so i
that was my grift for a long time and
then they ultimately booted my car which
is
crazy and they were like we finally
found you and i was like i've been
parking the same place every day
how hard
that's so funny i mean i used to park in
a high school parking lot my friend ezra
lived
right across the street in the high
school so there's a certain point where
i just parked at ezra's
uh because that way also i could walk
off campus
at lunch and nobody would know and then
i would you know because
they wouldn't see me drive off were you
a big skipper
did you leave often because i know you
said you were skipping in seventh grade
which i feel like is pretty early for a
skip
well i hated that it was a particular
dark
that was a not a great time for me yeah
you know my dad had just moved
and come you know come out as a drug
addict so i had a lot of other things
happening that sort of provoked that um
you know i mean i would skip once a
while
you know i'd fake sick uh yeah in terms
of in terms of like
leaving for blocks by the time
doing that i sort of was you know i was
the president of my high school
and i was very you know i guess this is
but the joke was that everyone called me
you know bueller everyone called me
ferris because i was sort of friends
with everybody i was friends with
all the clicks or you know uh
i had a click summit as president where
i got
a representative of each sort of group
and was like let's
all make senior year about [ __ ] on
the teachers and the parents and not
about [ __ ] on each other
oh my god so you were like we need class
solidarity literally among the clicks
yeah i got the big the way it happened
was i i was a terrible student so i like
blew off english and i failed my
second semester of junior year my
teacher miss moon was like the only way
you're gonna graduate on time is if you
do english double
your first year senior so i had to do
after school english
of course generally is populated by you
know folks who
are are not doing well or you know in
different ways
and from that i got to know one of the
biggest like
offenders like one of the biggest
abusers in the school was in the class
and i mean this is so cliche but like i
would like you know we'd read
something like shakespeare's something
and i would do voices and stuff and
they sort of over time like got into
doing that they got into performing
too and then that opened the door
to maybe people who perform maybe people
who are
different are not as bad as you think
and basically i you know uh
befriended the biggest sort of abuser in
the school
and just tried to talk to him about why
it doesn't make people feel good and it
doesn't make him feel good to do
what they're doing and then over time uh
yeah you would see you would see this
two kids who got into a
furious fist fight in my sophomore year
uh helping each other out you know
one grabbing a dessert for the other one
in the cafeteria
so in that sense i felt like i did a
good job in high school
that way um unifying the school
but the other thing was that uh i
befriended the superintendent
their their office was on the school
grounds so one of the big things with
the superintendent is that uh
it started to be that her assistant
would phone into the classroom i was in
and go anthony what do you want for
lunch and then i would place my lunch
order
with the superintendent's office and
then they would bring me
my food so like did the superintendent
know like was this because the
superintendent knew like anthony created
peace among the clicks
he's the one who's holding things
together here
i mean i don't think it was like a
warring high school before it's a very
tame
you know uh thing no i i think what
happened was that
i i just i think that's a personality
survival technique of mine which is know
the power
where's the power and know the power
because that's how you survive and it's
good to have the power on your side
um and then i think the other thing was
i was pretty invested in
changing things in the town that i saw
were inequalities so like having a
student representative on the
parent-teacher school board
and um you know uh advancing the idea of
condom distribution and better sex
education in the school
you know in the height of the aids
crisis
um and so i uh you know the governor
came to our school
because of some of the things i had done
so they also sort of
i think knew that uh you know
i i uh uh wasn't gonna go away and it
was a big scandal when i got elected
because i wasn't from hamilton when i'm
i was from chelsea and it was like
what's this
there was you know people who said he
shouldn't even be allowed to be this
president of the school
because he's a jew from chelsea
that's not that's true so
to be just the class president i feel
like school school president school
president and the reason i correct
is just because you it can actually
affect the town's policy like
and i i i was a video geek so i also
filmed the selectmen meetings and my
friend ben's dad was on the selectmen
committee
and so i also was getting into
understanding how government worked
and so i was starting to use the bylaws
of the town
to create new liberties for
young people in the town and trying to
advance
propositions and things in the town to
solidify the
not as school policy but as town policy
so this wasn't just a position where
like you're doing the morning
announcements and planning the dances
this
is i mean i did that too yeah so yeah
like
like walk me through the duties of the
school president then because i
was i've noticed those were the duties
of the school president were make sure
you have a great homecoming and come out
and rahra says
and do the school announcements and do
all that
but i was like i because i have
inflated sense of self was like this is
my chance to grab
power okay and and i and i think the
thing was that
i had never been involved in scooting
could give a [ __ ] about student
government
could have cared less i was doing school
plays
hanging out with friends you know
whatever and i was in this class with
this guy mr cadarus who had had a brain
tumor
and he had it removed and uh we would
all make fun of him for it
he'd like forget something and we were
like oh mr carys looks like i was like
the
main offender and then i would do an
impression of him to do the school
announcements
so i'd be like this is mr doris uh
everybody listen oh
i lost my thought you know i do stupid
things like that mr kadaris kind of
sounds a little like bernie sanders
yeah he did yeah i mean yeah and uh
so there was this girl emily who was in
my math class with miss godaritz and she
was like a real go-getter emily was a
real go-getter
and she was her dream and she was gonna
run for school president
and being a dick when she announced it
uh in class i stood up and went you know
what emily if you can run
i'm running too you tracy flicked her
you
did an election on her i did an election
on her
and i then got my friend ben twining who
was like
you know generations in hamilton one of
the most established hamilton families
goes back to the twining tea company
i made him my vice president so he's the
joe to your obama in oa you need to get
an establishment
a long-term person in there yeah to make
people know that you're safe yes and
then i
and then i did all jimmy what a white
thing this is i did all james brown
lyrics for my posters so i'd be like you
know get off on the good foot vote
anthony of taminic i put those posters
all over the place
and then uh in the debates i held up a
condom
and showed it to emily and go what are
you so afraid of and of course she's a
lesbian now so now i understand
and um she was a lesbian then but she's
out now
and uh uh and then the thing
happened with her that was sort of like
rough with her family and
this adopted brother and she was off the
grid for a little while and so
um i took advantage of that um
and a politician would as any politician
would
and then when i got elected we had a
summit at my friend's house
where i asked her to be uh the treasurer
and i made a unity government where she
would then join
i actually when obama's hillary has a
secretary of state
yeah when i when that happened i wrote
her and i go can you believe that we
because we're still like we're we're
like not like good friends but like we
get in touch we've had drinks in boston
and it's and one of the big things was
when i saw her one time i said i'm so
sorry for what i did to you
because i i made it a total joke and you
really cared about it and i just
took it from you for no reason because i
just wanted to prove that i could
so i look back on that as like really
something that was very arrogant
and um you know it's one you know
because i was
taught classes with you it's one of the
reasons why i think long before
any of this stuff was um what would you
call trendy now
uh i used to always say who's the
biggest enemy in the room and it's the
young white man and the reason why is
because i was that i mean i am that but
i'm
not young anymore but i knew all that i
knew what that aggression is
and that and then not even aggression
but just laid fair carelessness like
just like not caring about
what you did or how you affected other
people and seeing yourself as the center
of it all
and of course that's rooted in a lot of
insecurity i mean you know people don't
want
i understand why people don't want to
talk about that part of it but like
someday we'll have to address that part
of it because that is part of it
we keep we'll keep producing men the way
they are
until we address all the things of why
we experience this
because it's it's we're not born that
way you know
and you know one of the things in doing
this podcast and just interviewing
people
is like is talking to uh men about this
like deep insecurity that they have
during this time and how like actually
really really sensitive a teenage boy is
oh um but like the messages that they
get are so
mixed that it becomes a really volatile
combination um one thing i wanted to ask
you
so what was your relationship to like
the politics of the time and stuff
because obviously you're like really
a political voice now but were you
what was your what were you what were
teen anthony's politics like
you know oh everyone's gonna be
mortified so team anthony really
talking about insecurity and masculinity
and all these things
i was a big geek i didn't really have
any girlfriends
you know i had crushes and then i had
like one girl i had a girlfriend for
sort of junior senior year but that was
like a totally messed up situation
and then of course the other girl i had
a huge crush on
who i actually found a tranche of
letters from her the last time i was
home
and i had never grieved her because she
she uh
she passed away tragically in 2004.
and she was one of my best friends in
high school and i totally blocked her
out
and i found all these letters and it was
i mean that was
it was a crazy experience to realize
you had a crush on or did you date her
no no i i had a crush we so i had an
unrequited almost in seriously toxic
crush on her
we became classic story became friends
then i abused her a bunch you know
verbally and
you know all that but she was my big
lesson
because uh i you know when i would feel
rejected of course i would do hateful
things or you know hateful note or
whatever
and uh she came into study hall one time
and confronted me
uh pulled me over to the what they call
the choir benches which is where they
keep the choir seats
and she very soberly was like i like you
you're my friend
i don't like you that way and what
devastates me
is that if you don't stop doing this i
will never speak with you again
wow what a mature thing for her to like
be able to
say too yes yes and so that killed me
and i of course for years before i
really
reckoned with that type of thinking i
think but like the
long and the short is uh uh that then
then something happened where i
understood my first real
friendship with a woman like my first i
mean i had friendships
obviously i had friendships with girls
and stuff but like this was my first
friendship
after that and it deepened it and then
uh there were definitely and then we
went through a lot of different things i
became
very close with that family and with the
siblings and in fact they
saw me at ucb and i you know and and uh
years later i mean i saw them when they
were eight and here they are 22
23. and um uh
uh yeah very that's one of the most you
know
everyone i think will have has one true
painful
sort of wish you could really figure out
how to undo it
and i don't mean that part i mean how to
undo her death
or how to undo not communicating maybe
near the end or whatever
that's my that would be mine yeah
so that high school story but i guess
i'm sorry i totally derailed
the question but it was related which
was you
you were asking we talked about
your politics at the time oh politics oh
this is why
so the reason why is because in my
family my uncle's side of the family is
very very reagan
became reagan reagan democrats who
became bushes and that was the dominant
part of my family
so i went through that period you know
where you go well that's how you
identify as tough
so i went through a very brief period
where i was like i like bush you know
it's fine
it's good and i was like supporting bush
um
and uh then by the time i got to high
school
um oh no i'm sorry let me flip it
i was a rat i'm sorry that happened that
happened later that happened like by my
senior year
where bill weld was a governor and
visited he was a republican
so i'm sorry i flipped the script um
that at the beginning was me being very
anti-bush anti-rag and all this
protesting the original gulf war
painting patton's tank
green uh blue pink in the park at night
um and rebellious and i stayed
rebellious including with all the aids
education stuff and all that
i think by the time i got to um there
was it was really i guess just a year
where i sort of became like an alex p
keaton and was like you know it was like
i don't know i like bush and [ __ ] this
and [ __ ] liberals and i
i went through that phase and then of
course clinton came around and then i
went oh no but i was a jerry brown
person so
i guess you could say i've always been
this which i think i still
am which is i'm ra i'm i'm i don't
consider it radical but i'm
very very left but i can't stand
people who advocate leftism do you
remember like your main
forms of media when you were a kid like
were you into
were you an mtv kid did you like zines
like that kind of
where were you getting well i read the
boston phoenix i read
i read you know punk scenes uh
i yeah i watched mtv i watched comedy
channel which used to be
you know before comedy central and ha
and comedy channel merged
that's how you know an old person um i
watched a lot of old you know i watched
a lot of creature double feature movies
and um
you know uh the prisoner i loved kid
spirit and then i would
my friend dave i love going to occult
book shops i love finding
books on masonry freemasonry i mean i'm
surprised i didn't become a q an honor
based on my trajectory when i was
younger i'm amazed i'm not like that
um but yeah definitely like you know and
i
i was into s i would watch sports but i
wasn't particularly into that i could
really care less were you doing dragons
kid
d and d but d and d when i was like
you know up to like seventh grade not
past that
uh video games and you know video games
music video but
movies video games and [ __ ] that was
pretty much that was pretty much my
my my jag and i'd watch a lot of action
adventure and
sci-fi things like that all right let's
take actually a look at the
photos that you sent you sent us two
so sorry i couldn't find more oh please
no two is perfect i think this first one
segues in because we were talking a
little bit about
music so what are we looking at here it
looks like you're at a con
you're at a baseball game or something
right we're at a we're at dodger stadium
uh and this is in 1990
and uh that's me with my pop i think
that that is probably
summer so this is the between junior and
senior year
and we my dad played for emmy lou harris
that's awesome
a big musician so i think
this trip was when i met arsenio hall
and
we went to their city hall show and i
met lou diamond phillips and
rosie o'donnell uh
when i was 15 i think this picture
so was your dad just like a person who
could get you backstage
at things well my dad's a drummer yeah
yeah
so you that's how is that how you met
them
i just toured with them like so i was on
the bus i was like okay
it was like a family trip and emmy's
daughter went to a school
near where i went to school so uh you
know
it was a family affair i mean that the
the best thing was going on tour with
them
uh you know and still it's like when i
had the show i got it you know my dad
said oh emme
emmy saw your show you know this that's
like family that that band i mean sam
bush who's one of the great
mandolin players of all time and uh
a man roy husky jr who passed away who
was one of the most legendary bluegrass
um bassists that ever lived
um so i was hanging out with incredible
uh uh artists it was wild you know and
then
and then there's my dad eating a hot dog
so i think we went to this ball game and
this was also intense because this is
where
i probably had my first confrontation
with my dad confronting him about
um just about
why he left and all that stuff so it's
interesting because this
marks a major turning point where i
feared that confronting my dad would
somehow
make him go away and then actually it
led to the
really uh incredible relationship i had
with my dad now
my dad basically looks the same which is
great
he really does um i was i was gonna ask
like
when you're how long did you tour with
them did you live on the bus and all
that stuff
oh it was oh it was just like a for the
summer it'd be three weeks you'd pick up
on the tour okay
we're in part you know we went to
letterman one year
and then i think this year was the
california east coast one time and then
west coast
yeah so yeah but no not the whole time
but it was
uh uh you know i don't think they wanted
a kid on the bus for really
well that's what i was wondering is i
was like how long
do they want the seventh grader on the
bus
yeah i mean i was i will say this is
where like i'm fortunate
in the sense that i was you know my
whole life i don't know
i feel like if i look back my point of
view has not changed since i remember my
first
image sitting in a carriage like i can
remember sitting in a carriage in the
driveway and i know my mind was the same
as it is now
i just i know it because i remember the
point of you remember being like oh
where the [ __ ] are we going so
i don't think anything's ever changed
for me and so i
i knew when to be cool i knew not to be
a spaz
you know i you know you just know that
you know you're not supposed to do that
i probably over talked sometimes but
you know and also you're watching real
adult [ __ ] you know you're watching
people
pull down an entire bottle of jack
daniels before they go perform and
all that so it's pretty cool to watch
yeah
that's um that's like a really
incredible
unique uh experience
yeah it's it's so it's only lately in my
life i've realized when i tell people
about my life they're like what
and i'm like i get i mean i don't
consider it a particularly
i feel like it's a very passive
passenger life for the most part i sort
of witnessed other things
um but i guess it's just normal to me
because that was my life
and were you interested in comedy at
this time or like when did that
make its way into your world because i
know you said you were doing the plays
in school
oh well i mean i was watching sctv and
you know snl obviously when i was a kid
uh but i watch sctv when i go up to
toronto to visit my
dad's uh my grandmother so um i was
always in the sketch comedy and kids in
the hall and all that
um and i think in probably what
seventh grade sixth grade i started
making little comedy videos
um very rudimentary on vhs and then
um i did uh um stand up at glenarc i
used to do
uh that you had these you know uh
wednesday uh things
and uh every month you'd have a talent
thing so i would i would do impressions
of the teachers
and uh so i was doing that and then i
was doing improv what i was doing um
uh short form improv my what 10th grade
year
so that would have been 1990. so
that's 31 years i've been improvising in
one way or
one the other and then
i would say that um you know hanging
around with everyone on the bus
you really just kept getting exposed to
more and more comedy so i would say like
i but i always want to be a filmmaker so
i always i went to school for film and
power i think it was like film and
politics those were sort of where i was
angling and everyone in my family was a
lawyer so i thought i was gonna just get
a law degree and practice law
and then it was in college when i when i
uh
really realized from high school doing
the friday night
festivals we called them where we did
laun we did short form
when i went to college then i then i
started doing i joined a comedy
group i i auditioned for my high school
improv team which was short form and it
was run
by four of by my estimation the cutest
boys i've ever seen in my life
and so um i forgot the rules of the game
that they told us
okay we're ending this and they were
like not nice about it and i did not get
on the improv team
and i just completely like glazed over
with my crush on them and couldn't
i couldn't remember what they had told
me what's so funny
you're such a horny teen like you have
like two boyfriends and you're like all
into
i was like the opposite i was so not
connected with myself
i was
i was i would say even more than
horniness
it was like a i wanted romance
it was crushiness romance yeah yeah i
wanted like like i
i would get so moved by like the teen
programs that i was watching like i've
talked on the podcast about crying to an
episode of the oc
when seth claims his love for summer
like i would be
i wanted a boyfriend so
badly that whenever whenever one would
present himself to me i'd be like yes
they're in love and then like
everything would be dramatic and that's
just kind of what i knew
oh i was so wound so tight that like
even the notion of expressing that you
like someone was
just a humiliating like i that was like
that was just not even accessible to me
in high school it was a point of shame
it was nice number one focus was like
love and being loved and like
having a romance of some kind
well i'll say something i remember that
thinking about it now and i don't know
if this will get me in trouble i guess
but like
yeah i looked at my high school yearbook
the other day and i was like looking at
it i was looking
at the pictures of the class and i went
oh my god i go so many of the girls in
this class were beautiful
you know and and i think to myself
how judgmental and afraid i was
of rel like any sort of relationship
like that and i think about
like how if i had the chance like how
uh awesome it would have been to have
had some confidence
and gotten to know some of the women and
that i
maybe have been interested in and i
so judged people that
i erased i think a lot of possibilities
for myself because there were some
people look at and go i knew they had a
crush on me
maybe you know that sort of thing i just
was totally blind
blind to all of that and uh i never let
a crush go by
i never i never missed one and i never
let him get by me
no no i had too [ __ ] up a childhood
that
like accessing that stuff was not
possible for
years that's so that is my oh boy
let's talk about this photo here
is this a school dance who are we
looking at here
all right so that's best friend dave and
that's me
on the left uh very thin as you can see
which is extremely thin
with the short haircut with no sideburns
which is my favorite
i look like a [ __ ] mass shooter i
mean i really do
like i am going to shoot up the school
and that's lori amaral
and you could see you have to remember
that this is 1990 so that's
very we are all very alt
because i'm a skinhead who's growing his
hair back out
at that point dave is punk with the long
shade over one eye thing normally
hanging over one eye
and laurie has dyed blonde hair okay
and we were a crew of about seven of us
who
went and listened to the smiths and hung
out at different people's apartments
lori has riot girl energy oh
yes she did laurie and laurie was i
think a junior
so we were all such friends and lori
didn't have a date you know it was one
of those things
uh she didn't have a date and then dave
and i were like we'll both go with you
and she was like cool let's all do it so
then i went and found my
grandfather's my dead grandfather's
towering and we were obsessed with
towering inferno dave and i were
and they had those crazy tuxes you know
from towering and furniture
and i went dude i found towering inferno
tuxes
and so they were in my grandfather's
closet so we wore
my dead grandfather's tuxes to this
dance and this was the junior year dance
were other guys wearing tuxes
at the dance because our dance they
didn't wear tuxes
no oh well no no i'm sorry yes no junior
probably oh yeah you'd wear
rent to talks of course yeah no i'm
that's totally
no i feel like my problem it was they
wore suits
no no you wore tuxes at proms you could
dress any way you wanted in a dance
but at the junior and the senior prom
you had to wear
a tux yeah absolutely okay so then and
this was senior prom
this was her junior pro her junior prom
and you guys went with her that's
adorable
i love the tuxedo it's it's kind of
beautiful that they ended up both
fitting you guys
i know yours looks like it looks a
little big on you
mine's a little big on me i think dave
would just fit right but like you really
it's funny i look so much like my cousin
jacob my
david's son jacob it's wild to look at i
don't really look at this picture
because dave said this to me
um but you could see what uh you know
here's a thing the high school lens and
i realized
the body dysmorphia is something i deal
i have
i don't really ever talk about it but
even when i lose weight
i always think i don't look good i
always think and it's so funny
when you have enough distance i go i was
a handsome young man
you know i did not think that about
myself at the time
no i thought i was just a jewish troll
and and i look at it now and i go i was
actually a very square
jaw you know a nice jaw cut handsome guy
i know people could be like oh my god
anthony relax but
it's it's for me it's big because i
hated myself
hated myself he did myself
it's really it is interesting to look
back at that stuff
and we've had a lot of people on the
podcast express that same thing of being
like
i wish that i could go back and tell
myself that i was a cutie pie
and like you know what you can
you know you can so here's you know me
this is the
anthony teaching improv i can't wait you
can because
your mind is a congress right i've
talked about that before
and it's true and there's all these
parts of you and if you really want to
think about what you can do
is in your mind start imagining that
self
when you're quiet and talk to it
because that self is still there and i
guarantee you that self is undermining
you in some way in your life because
it's trying to protect you
so you got to go to the child and the
high school self and the 20 self and the
panicked self
which are all representations of
different parts of your psyche that take
over in moments of protection or moments
of panic or
moments of love all the different
identities that you have
and i like multiple personalities just
identity we all know this we
know identities sit in the wings we know
when we hear
aspects of ourselves basically congress
with each other to decide how we're
gonna
do it if you slow your mind down enough
you can actually really identify and
isolate and have a relationship with
them
and uh you can you can heal you can heal
that you can say to that self
you're okay you're good and i love you
and it seems so cheesy listen i know it
sounds cheesy and stupid
uh i get where people would reject that
or groan
i always just say what are you so afraid
of what's what's 10 minutes of your life
to just sit and do that
and what if nothing happens who's the
embarrassment you
you're alone you don't have to tell
anybody you're doing it you could do it
in your mind
um but i think it's really important
yeah and that's actually
that is a very perfect way for us to
segment to my last question on the
podcast i feel like i can talk to you
forever
about it i know i'm sorry i run at the
mouth yeah please
but our final question that i ask
everyone is
if you could talk to teen anthony what
would you tell him
or when you talk to teen anthony later
in your mind
uh if i could really time travel i would
tell teen anthony
um people like you
people love you you don't need to be so
scared
and um
trust yourself more and and love
yourself more
yeah that's what i would say and and i
would go tell
allison not to go drinking on the roof
of a building
that's what i would do i'm serious those
would be that would be the warning
uh that would be probably that would be
the thing
anthony thank you so much for coming on
the podcast and for everybody listening
at home
this has been the roast of your teenage
self podcast
you